[Aplausos]
ah
16 4
por esa canción
el mar
[Música]
una combinación de personajes y una
licuadora
y ésta
fue que yo soy yo
[Aplausos]
de 13 años hubiera visto atrás entre una
bola de cristal y esa foto derecho sí sí
sí soy yo
entonces ustedes
años
[Música]
estaría feliz estaría triste excepcional
nuestra mamá cuenta super feliz no puede
creer que está
empresaria desde millones
nos preocupamos por complacer a nuestra
mamá a nuestro papá a res tres tíos
primos novios y nos olvidamos de la
parte de la persona que confió en
nosotros
nuestro yo de cinco años nuestro de años
nuestro de 13 7 20 y los pueblos
primeros que confiaron en nosotros
porque no tenía límites
si yo voy a ser cantante si yo voy a ser
el modelo cooper o astronauta y no tenía
ese ser registrar es porque ellos
estudian estos muchos hombres toda la
traza por el de hambre mejor ser cabeza
de ratón que cola de león o sea para que
estudiarse esos dos temas a cazar y
dedicar de la familia a ella nos después
es más yo los escuché de gente
supercanal y amigos primos mejores
amigas
y por suerte lo escuché de mi mamá mi
papá los pilares más importantes
pero hacemos miles de personas que
quisieron tirar mis sueños
y otros que parecen dieron a loca pero
no mencionan los sueños
el primer paso al suelo que está
viviendo el día de los verbos persona
intercambiando artistas en cuatro reinos
y esfuerzo
la ciudad es que un fotógrafo
soportará y el mente solamente el padre
de la internet y yo participe con él de
varias campañas
y bueno aprender a modelar todo
sería una campaña muy importante
y ahora el país estará con los centros
comerciales más grandes de europa
tienes un día realmente conversar a
comer y mi fondo estaba por todo el
centro comercial
[Música]
como ellos quieran vivir un sueño
delante de mí
cinco años mi sueño era tener una vida
de película el día de hoy va a ser feliz
y yo mis hermanas
quedan en un día
d
o sea que estás a dieta disfrutando de
intercambio la verdad es que
sólo lo logra un millón
y yo como en la vida había luchado por
el té que es modelo porque yo toda mi
vida que es conservas
[Música]
a decirme eso y les tengo que confesar
que cuando me dijo esta villa sobre lo
logrado millones yo lo pude contestar
nada porque yo el certamen
[Música]
y yo me quedé callada es así tiene que
cabeza ya esta reconversión
las universidades más importantes de mi
país
el camino del éxito
pero se preguntarán
a ver todo esto con ellas y si ganar
y bueno pues me puse a analizar todo lo
que ella estaba enseñando todo lo que
ella tiene en común
además de lentejuela sartén super patria
no es que todas son resilientes
es la capacidad
para adaptarse positivamente a
situaciones adversas
no sé si nos va a cortar todos los
líderes de votos
todas las personas exitosas son
residentes así que aquí vienen mis pasos
para hacer las personas bibliotecas
personales favoritos no buscan una
madrina rodea
como tuve a mis hermanas todas tuve a la
madrina mejores amigas que ardiese
caracas deferencia tristísima antes de
que yo
había muchísimo que puedes cargar esta
acción es la persona más
tiene ya no hubieras previo entonces es
muy corta
les aporte si no estarán felices
número 2 y el mejor aperitivo para
hablar de metas ponga su pena a tratar
plante el plan de estrategia tránsito
por las herramientas y chiquitas diaria
de nacer locales el conocerse cinco años
no es algo de trabajo ya es agrupar que
es tu plan es 25 años pero así que estoy
haciendo hoy para hacer esa persona
ser un perdedor tiene porqué ser de tres
películas perder los días como siempre
la película emprendedora con la que
quería romper una pierna buena suerte no
tengo bien buena perdedora
significa que ella
[Aplausos]
era una persona disciplinada
y ella se resistió por haber perdido
es un clásico para hablar de ella
y el mundo de personas de esa persona
con grises negros café llegó de rojo
fuerte
qué bueno
lizzie mcguire que recordar de actitud
positiva sin personaje torpe y la mano
que estoy hablando de la torpeza física
porque muchos consejos como ya otros
gracias a dios no
pero no
no nos podemos levantar otra vez que
acabar el episodio con nuestros mejores
amigos nuestros papás felices lo peor
que puede pasar cuando te caes en que te
levantes
[Música]
en el piso un ratito y como ya todas las
prácticas posiciones y ha cocinado el
mal ahorita pero la verdad es
muy bueno
qué mejor
el aire seco también disfruta la vida
siempre va a tener otra pestaña un
collar preparando una presentación
dios quiere enviar
y es cierto ni siquiera escaleras dejo
que me caiste levantarse vivientes
caldas
de repente corres
entonces aprovecha la vista porque los
padres que el éxito es una nota que
pueden contar es virtual
donde estaban otros niños
interiores dice
y tú puedes ver en perspectiva que a
dónde puedo llegar
y bueno trabaja duro para tener a la
fuerte ser perseverante ser disciplinado
y cuando menos te des cuenta vas a estar
viviendo el cuento de siempre
una vez en canciones favoritas seguidos
siempre quiere que siempre estás
utilizando se prepara de personas
negativas que te van a quedar tiranos y
tú
tal vez ellos no tienen el mismo
pensamiento tal vez yo pudiera llegar
tan lejos entienden los agradeceros no
nos escuchen escucha a las personas que
te aporten
porque si a mí me hubiera dado pena el
hombre estaría que lea de bolsillo
novedad opuesta que mi valor que estaban
aquí y aquí y no en los likes los
colores las piernas la ropa el verdadero
valor de una persona está en las metas
unidades los sueños cumplidos por la
gente exitosa que respirar y de las
personas que no les dio miedo
jugar el juego y el temporal
escucha de boca de 5 años de 6 de 8 a 23
muchísimas grandes